bien alors maintenant on va passer au
secret d'état on va entrer dans le vif
du sujet avec pierre péan soldats
lorsqu'ils vont bien dire quand on lit
votre ouvrage on se dit que même l'état
le plus démocratique du monde est obligé
d'avoir des secrets d'état
absolument il peut pas vivre autrement
il ya des choses qu'elles sont qu'ils
doivent être caché ce conseil a pas de
en fait ça permet le secret permet
d'avoir un côté légal est inquiet une
autre logique une ce que j'appellerais
une c'est une logique régaliennes et
bien entendu plus un état est
totalitaire et plus au contraire le
domaine du secret d'état est immense
l'apprenant l'union soviétique même
l'annuaire du téléphone n'est secret est
donc là il ya plus besoin dit il n'y a
pas de deux secteurs il ya seulement un
facteur soumettre tous les tous les
numéros sont sur la liste rouge tous les
jours tous les numéros sont sur liste
rouge
ça me paraît normal bon alors se livrent
eux et examiner décortique tous les
rouages français du secret d'état
enfin c'est ce que j'essaie étoiles r
parce que lors de mes dernières enquêtes
notamment enfin quand les deux bombes ou
j'ai essayé de montrer comment la france
avait donné la bombe à israël entre 1956
et 1962 puis affaires africaines puis
ensuite les avants les fleurs j'ai eu un
bon palmarès un bar à jus j'avais j'ai
eu le sentiment et je crois que c'est
plus qu'un sentiment que j'ai été j'ai
touché la frontière du secret à
plusieurs moments et puis lors des
dernières affaires j'ai été plus que ça
semble-t-il baisse qui s'est produit pas
mal de turbulences j'ai eu le sentiment
en tout cas turbulences désagréable
certaine et donc et j'ai pris des notes
constamment parle pour tout ce qui s'est
passé autour de moi si je pense que même
si je les publier personne ne croirait
on pourrait créer un roman de série
noire donc j'ai il ya trois mots j'ai
cru comprendre que c'étaient des mots
comme sa raison d'état appareil d'état
et secret d'état et donc je voulais
j'ai voulu à un petit peu me pencher sur
qu'est-ce que tu qu'est-ce que tel
secret donc en main en tenant compte de
ce qui m'était parce que j'avais senti
plus ou moins et puis après j'ai re
mener une enquête au fond mal mon livre
c'est une enquête au pays du secret nous
allons vous parler de la dst et la dgse
du de la défense bien entendu du gic et
bien d'autres mais qu'est-ce que oui et
bien les choses oui il ya un passage qui
m'intéresse beaucoup c'est celui de la
fabrication d'un bombe atomique par le
ceva ou péan montre que ce sont les
ingénieurs qui ont imposé aux politiques
la construction d'un bombe atomique en
france c'est pas une décision politique
c'est une décision très politique a
toujours couru après les autres mais ça
n'était possible qu'avec le secret donc
c'est pour ça que je prends cet exemple
lorsque je montre aussi enfin ce que
j'essaie c2c de montrer que le secret
intéresse tout le monde intéresse on est
tous concernés par le secret parce que
quand il ya secret évidemment ça empiète
sur les libertés du citoyen vous ou moi
c'est à dire que le secret en fait créer
des sortes de forteresse d'efforts comme
des forteresses au moyen-âge où il ya
une circulation d'informations où il ya
des documents qui circulent mais vous ne
pouvez pas y aller où je ne peux pas y
aller oui mais sans ce que ce secret
d'état censés secret d'état et notre
pays seraient livrés car leur salon
lorsque j'explique ce que j'essaie
expliqué c'est que il ya une
justification à ce secret sait pas du
tout quelle est la justification
c'est tout simplement de la défense de
la france le secret c'est forteresse
temps en question permettent de
d'abriter de cacher des yeux etc
de cacher les intérêts vitaux de la
nation est donc un pays moderne est
obligé d'avoir ce secret parce qu'on est
dans une guerre et connaît même quand il
n'y a pas la guerre des armes il ya une
guerre économique et donc faut protéger
ses intérêts vitaux ne vous dit toutes
proportions gardées la raison d'état est
au pays ce que la légitime défense et à
l'individu l'autorisation de tuer c'est
à dire de transgresser la loi pour ne
pas être tués soit même absolument garde
donc fait il ya un équilibre une
démocratie c'est justement le pays qui
réussit à maintenir cette frontière de
façon raisonnable ou le secret qui
empiète sur la liberté des citoyens ne
va pas trop loin
un chapitre est consacré tous ces
documents innombrables marqués secret
alors il ya une hiérarchie qui l'ont
très secret oui j'ai été très loin dans
la machine les plus secrets et son mari
comment très secret défense très secret
défense d'après après il ya secret
défense que les temps après il ya
confidentiel défense puis on pourrait
continuer encore puisqu'il ya diffusion
restreint alors comment se fait-il que
c'est parfois c'est ces documents
marqués secret se retrouvent dans les
colonnes du canard enchaîné ou deux at
dans les journées à tarder elle sut très
secret défense
à ma connaissance on n'a jamais vu dans
la pré annonce à non c'est pas normal
personne n'oserait faire ça parce que
c'est un secret non mais c'est dangereux
c'est comme de la dynamique de m même si
par par inadvertance vous avez un secret
faut courir très vite pour aller à la
dst parce que sans ça il va vous arriver
des très très fort ennuis je vais
arriver des ennuis vous avez un c'est
pas pareil c'est non c'est quand j'ai
été très près de cette frontière
justement bon il m'arrivait
oui allez vous cambrioler d'envoyer les
jets
menaces de mort et j'ai eu un attentat
ainsi mais vous donner un exemple
l'intéressé est ici vous dit jean marie
pontaut alors journaliste au point un
put ainsi condamné pour violation du
secret défense pour avoir dans la sphère
des micros du canard enchaîné publié la
photo d'un agent de la dst et l'avoir
identifié oui c'est vrai et c'est exact
on avait on avait repéré un agent de la
dst et on avait juste on l'avait pris en
photo et puis mais il sait que ça
suffisait pas pour dire que c'était lui
on avait donc amené la concierge du
canard enchaîné qu'on avait cachée sur
une camionnette pour le repérer elle
nous avait dit oui c'est lui
or le canard enchaîné avait publié les
noms des agents ce qui était tout à fait
interdit et l'agent nous à nous a
poursuivis parce que on atteignait son
droit à l'image
et c'est nous qui avons été condamnés on
est le seul journal avait fait scandale
et pour les micros du canard enchaîné
alors qu'il avait dit la vérité leur
camp david a été et qu'on était bon
qu'il est ce qu'on ne pourrait pas dire
alors donné une autre définition du
secret d'état le secret d etat c'est
tout ce qui ne doit pas être confié aux
journalistes paco journalistes les
journalistes et c'est un citoyen comme
un autre il n'y a pas de il n'y a pas de
règlement sauf que le citoyen fait
cherche à percer les secrets qui
cherchent à percer mais mais mais j'en
connais pas qui cherche volontairement
des secrets défense parce que c ou d
très secret défense des excuses roland
jacquard il a quand même beaucoup
journalistes qui cherchent à part c'est
secret défense parce que bon nous ne
nous faisons pas d'illusions on vit dans
un monde où nous journalistes nous
abritons derrière le secret nos sources
si si je demande à tous les journalistes
qui sont là qui est dix mois la sphère
que tu as raconté donne moi ta source
on va s'abriter derrière secret des
sources mais la différence entre nous et
un agent de la dgse ou de la destine aux
services de renseignement quelconque
occidentale c'est que les informations
que donnent ces agents elles sont
ce sont des informations qui sont
classifiés par ordre d'importance quand
le président de la république le premier
ministre soit 20 bulletins de
renseignements on leur dit un groupe de
deux des farl va arriver en france
c'est une information de sources très
sûres - sur nous alors on n'a pas de
classification de ce genre on n'a pas de
le service de contre espionnage qui
seront capables de contrôler nos sources
donc on pouvait tomber souvent la
manipulation je pense je pense surtout
j'explique je crois que les vrais
secrets
c'est pas les secrets politiques les
vrais secrets c'est les secrets qui
concerne la bombe atomique
c'est les secrets qui concerne targé
tignes c'est à dire vers où sont pointés
les les ogives nucléaires
ça s'est livré ce cas où sont les sumos
sous marin il ya peut-être trois ou
servir tout à cela et à gap 3 4
personnes qui savent où sont les sous
marins il ya les grandes orientations du
conseil défense et ça je défie qui
compte que deux exemples vous donnez
page 147 vous parlez des points
sensibles
vous dites une commission
interministérielle s'occupe des points
sensibles donc et vous dit qu'il ya 2500
points sensibles civile donc ici sont
sensibles situe donc ils sont
il faut pas les connaître et vous donnez
irez vous dites alors un agent non mais
oui mais ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que ça les points sensibles à des
finitions c'est l'état a fait la nation
c'est commun comme un corps humain et
donc il ya des points sensibles en cas
de guerre donc ça c'est les jeunes je
parle des points sensibles et qui sont
protégés particulièrement ce qui
signifie donc il ya concrètement des
barbelés concrètement une difficulté est
rentré et concrètement aussi les agents
du contre espionnage et aider tous les
gens de la sécurité
regarde près ces points sensibles de
telle sorte de vérifier s'il est si
l'ennemi facile et si les agents
étrangers ne vont pas faciliter pas la
tâche des agents étrangers alors en
l'occurrence cette liste là elle est
tout à fait officielle à bord en bas
donc son temps qu'ils sont ses vrais
défauts de ce nom mais libre les 20
points peut être sens ils connus comme
tels et mes protégés au silo réseau
régis et c'est par réseau régis haiat
lorsque j'essaie aussi de montrer c'est
la machinerie mais non seulement les
agents de tous les gens de secret ils
ont besoin de communiquer entre eux
alors ils comines et que je parle donc
des valises concrètement il ya des
valises concrètement il ya des chiffres
le chiffre et puis aussi il ya des
téléphones qui sont tout à fait protéger
et donc à toute une série de téléphones
ne régit c est un de ceux là est un
attrait qui permet de relier les grands
disons aux fonctionnaires et ministres
clés d'exercer le certains numéros
d'urgence donne un cachet pas mais cela
dit vous connaissez vous le mur du
régime or j'en connais quelques-uns
non mais parce que maintenant vous savez
c'est facile à regarder non mais non
mais on ne peut pas le faire vous pouvez
pas faire ce numéro parce que il faut
avoir un poste il faut avoir un poste
dans la bo est pas le faire et vous
pouvez pas avoir une autre téléphone
c'était parallèle absolument honnêtement
harley vous savez les satellites et un
circuit fermé
cela dit les satellites qui soit
soviétique ou américains qui sont au
dessus
icap toutes les communications vous
savez c'est le fait que ce soit le
régissent ou un autre il ya toutes les
communications il ya même des
ordinateurs qui sont codifiés de telle
façon que certains ouvrages sont
automatiquement et puis j'apprends que
je pensais que les balises diplomatiques
étaient inviolables
elles sont régulièrement ouvertes quand
la dgse estime qu'il ya des chances
raisonnables que la pêche soit soucieuse
ce que j'essaie d'expliquer c'est qu'on
parle toujours de la de la dgse dans
quand il ya des choses qui ne marchent
pas alors ne le parle à la sphère
greenpeace mais je montre aussi qu'ils
sont assez efficaces même très efficace
sur un point bas bien particulier qui
s'appelle la documentation la deux
les prendre les documents bruts
interceptions documents bruts alors j'ai
dit que tous les à peu près tout enfin
tous les jours il ya entre dix et quinze
cambriolages par jour dans les grands
hôtels à paris à nice et puis aussi
quand les agences entre que la valise
diplômé une valise diplomatique et et
peut être bien mais l'essai de l'ouvrir
et à liège ouvre surtout s'il a rempli
d'explosifs
[Musique]